hello I seem fun friends this is the
intro to this week's I seem fun that's
right I'm driving and enjoying it on my
phone don't worry I'm hands-free now
you're probably wondering oh my god Jen
tipped an episode in the studio what's
going on is she a rich [ __ ] now the all
things Comedy Network go to all things
calm be calm is the fantastic podcast
network that my podcast is part of run
by comedians not the establishment
and they have beautiful studios that are
always at my disposal I've never used
them for my own podcast I've done other
people's podcast there but um such as
the crab feast and Eddie Pepitone pep
talks but we have a new social media
person at all things comedy and he
wanted to come and get a feel for my
podcast and periscope it live I don't
know if any of you watched that last
week that was sort of a surprise that
happened so this episode technically
technically has already aired live on
periscope last week kind anyway our new
guy Brendan was like yeah just let me
know I'll come watch and record it and I
was like well normal either in my bed so
that might be weird um why don't I do
one in the studio and then you can
you'll still get the same feel for what
I do and the pictures will look good
because they'll have the logo of all
things comedy and so I did an email
listener episode and the reason I chose
to do that a listener email episode the
reason I chose to do that is because I
print out the emails and I read them and
I like the feeling of being at a desk
sometimes when I'm at home and I do the
listener email episode to sit in my
office and my desk and it feels like
we're getting business done and I write
notes on the page as I read and it's a
lot when I'm recording my own off an app
and during listener you know episodes I
absolutely have screwed up my own
recordings you know there's been many
times I have hit pause when I didn't
know I did when I have accidentally
deleted something I've at least wasted a
few hours of my life
not actually recording when I thought I
was so I think when I have things in my
hands and want to look at my computer
reference something I think I like doing
that in this studio and its really good
for my voice because I can modulate
proper modulation my voice better and
everything's done and it's right in the
dropbox I don't have to upload something
and wait an hour so while I seem fun
episodes where I talk off the top of my
head and wander around my apartment for
inspiration those will always be the
heart of I seem fun but I made once in a
while hit the studio to do our listener
email episodes where I feel very
official and like I'm broadcasting to
you from somewhere very special so I
hope you enjoyed it and go to jen
kirkman com click on tour dates there
are tickets on sale right now for
Toronto Vancouver Winnipeg London
Manchester burlington vermont Scottsdale
Arizona and Los Angeles
I would encourage you all to buy tickets
in advance some people ask me if I ever
ad shows if I sell out no because you
people buy tickets at the door you can
add a show that night but if things sell
out in advance i can add shows I can
play bigger venues it's really a nice
thing you can do for an artist buying
the tickets in advance especially if you
know you're coming and if you can't come
you can always sell them there are
always and one people on Twitter and I
retweet if people can't come and they
want to sell their tickets if it's I'll
help you out
but i really encourage the advance
ticket sales this is how people move to
the next level someone came up to me in
Minneapolis I think you play a bigger
venue I was like no I can't actually
it's if there's a science to this we've
got it figured out but thank you for
your suggestion um if a good of what
we're not there yet but what helps us
get there is advanced ticket sales
creates a buzz and a hype the show sells
out people that didn't get in go what
was how come I missed out and I'll go
next time the audio version of my book I
know what I'm doing another lies i tell
myself is available on audible or itunes
but you'll find everything on my website
that that you could ever need go to
itunes by the way subscribe even if you
don't listen it gets my numbers up in
that top 100 of people out actually
subscribe and leave a five-star review
you can write um you can write something
snarky instead of sincere thing I know
that there is a my fan not my fan this
woman that is a I have someone stalking
me they keep changing their identity
first there a man then they say they're
a trans woman then they say they're a
person of color I don't they stock me
online they were the ones that were
trying to disrupt my show in San
Francisco they have now taken to writing
nasty reviews on my itunes because i am
going to vote for Hillary in the general
election I don't really understand it
but in in my incessant making fun of
Bernie Bros on Twitter which has nothing
to do with Bernie well listen it does
come from the top down but you not I'm
saying make in front of the young people
not the ones that believe in change but
the ones that troll forwards and start
writing to me Hillary Clinton stood in
front of four dead bodies so I'll always
make fun of those people I'll never stop
and it gets me threats so maybe I should
stop I probably will not because I've
been silent but because I value my life
so you know you can counterbalance that
psychos iTunes um reviews and you can
write uh I don't know what would you
write don't write anything about her
obviously hard I know people are stupid
and they will just write love the haters
how's that ok enjoy this week's episode
diary of Jeff
I see the numbers you guys you've just
heard the theme song JK here this is I
seem fun the diary Jen Kirkman podcast
the first one not taped from my home
that's a lie I've taped many on the road
are you nodding Aaron because of that
fact or those sound Oh Dean listen my
podcast no you don't it's okay uh oh my
god I think it was one of the first I
don't know if I would I don't know if
that's true I just know al Madrigal call
me you can get in on the ground floor um
listen I'm at the studio built by hand
no of al Madrigal and Bill vers all
things comedy network I never come to
the studio because I'm not good with
booking time I'm not good with staying
on time i'm not good with remembering i
have to do stuff I so I want to explain
if anyone seeing this I do have a coffee
I found out it's a whole thing you guys
don't know about that my beautiful fans
of the podcast to my voice is [ __ ] up
because i had this acid reflux i didn't
know about it was silent it was coming
up for years that's why it sounded like
this and it's getting a lot better i'm
on a special diet but coffee was
something they said to stay away from
but i just found out coffees kind of a
neutral it's not quite that acidic and
it's okay to have in moderation so i
have a decaf with lots of almond milk
twice a week and i probably won't even
finish this whole thing but I feel like
it helps my a.d.d okay great story here
we go and this I know you guys are like
why does anyone listen to this podcast
the people are [ __ ] weird they like
to listen to me when they're doing their
laundry or walking around a lot of
couples listen in bed one person is not
a fan the other one is and is trying to
avoid sex a lot of people love this to
my friends in the room brenton who works
for all things comedy his beautiful
girlfriend cassie is here visiting and
producer Aaron they're probably like
this is born but listen you can go go we
go listen to someone's going to
interview someone go get up right now
I'm sure somewhere down the hall
two comedians one comedian is talking to
a more successful comedian and then
they'll post that and it'll be great or
one comedian is successful and they now
have access to famous people and they're
talking what oh [ __ ] don't even put that
on periscope don't put what just
happened don't tell bill burr won't kill
me kill me once he finds out who I am
now listen we're beginning okay I love
you all to this is a listener email
episode can I take this mic out no I
cannot I can move it though like that's
right oh that's good I'm gonna put my
feet up so uh you people you you people
the fans there's a lot of dead spot
silence in my podcast to and actually in
real life IRL I had to pee before this
started in real life I would just start
recording at home and then go pee not so
they could hear it but I'd run away and
like put some music on or just leave it
silent people don't care that's how
starve they are for anything they really
just don't care anymore how they're
treated okay so this week listeners
wrote in emails it can be questions it
can be hey should I tweet out that I'm
being periscope trite now okay hang on
one sec see this means nothing now you
don't periscope the whole thing do you
oh you can periscope as much as you want
okay great I didn't know how that I
haven't used my periscope not a long
time oh my god it says no service in
here is there Wi-Fi oh okay so guys as
we're talking this is so I seem fun you
don't even understand let me just get
connected to my wireless do you
understand is that the password that
weird word under it are you allowed to
say Wi-Fi passwords on the air is that
I'm not going to but I'm just saying in
general in society is that a thing that
has to be very secret it seems like the
one password that you can be like you
know what the Wi-Fi password is it
studio 8 where I tape at midnight or you
know whatever that's not like a security
risk I'm not going to do it just in case
it is but I'm just saying someone
tweeted at me today that Bill Clinton is
a Nazi didn't I didn't know I H a mas
this password is the word Hamas in it
somewhere I'm just saying maybe I should
report it to someone I fit i think i
just joined hamas putting that past
conan ok here we go all right now I'm
gonna pretend like you guys aren't here
because if I start performing my voice
changes and it's annoying people they
have to feel like I'm just talking to
them we're gonna get back into that
register guys I'm guys I'm live what's
the periscope address oh I'm live on
periscope taping and I seem fun in
studio right now airs next week just in
case they're gonna be like my I do you
think even auto crap just wanted to
change this to AIDS next week I hope not
uh hang on one sec also earlier today my
autocorrect a corrected platonic to
playboy which it was funny it's two very
different things ok here we go ok ok so
let's see what people have to say this
week hi Jen don't use my name I've been
listening to the podcast from the
beginning and that it's and this it
people ok this is his sentence I have
been listening to the podcast from the
beginning and this it's absolutely
hilarious thank you I wanted to let you
know that I've become a fan of going on
vacation alone I have been unemployed
for the last month don't worry haters
i'm fine i saved my money and have
something new lined up so [ __ ] off ok i
have been basically been traveling
around the US on my own for the last
three weeks they have been the fundus
spelled wrong trips I've ever been on
I've met so many new people and have had
a blast I don't know why more people
don't travel alone I don't have to worry
about anyone and can do whatever the
without an e hell I want I'm being such
a [ __ ] about the spelling who cares I
now hate the thought of going on
vacation with friends or family I
probably wouldn't have done this if it
weren't for the podcast thank you okay
that's not there's more to it but I need
to stop here and explain to people that
i have just influence someone to live
their life differently i have just
influenced someone to waste gas not
carpool use up resources in a hotel by
themselves as we sit here we're the
pacific garbage patch and probably 20
good years left before we start dying in
natural disasters so thank you you're
welcome also the music you listen to on
the podcast is fantastic I'm in my 20s
in the music my generation listens to is
shipped I'd rather hear a bulimic be
elem I see puke all day long at least
you got this one annoys me when people
say oh she's anorexic she throws up two
separate things he xyx do not throw up
bulimics do i normally listen while
driving so i can't write it down when
you mention the song is there any way
you can put the music played on the
podcast and is in the description
already [ __ ] stupid no ass this is
okay first of all and I say this with
love to everyone don't ask stupid
[ __ ] questions yeah why don't I put
the name of a song on the internet and
announce that I'm playing it I'm sure
Elton John the estate of prints and
other people will be like cool we
definitely won't try to get money from
her no I cannot do that also I know
you're normally driving when you listen
to the podcast but you can do this thing
where you get home and you can relist
into it then I'm listen I'm not in the
best mood I'm not the worst mood but I
definitely
I'm just I'm telling it like it is
that's what I love about you she tells
it like it is I don't have time to tell
it like it is i'm in my cubicle taking
care of my family that's a recurring
character called the live laugh love
lady sir i cannot but there is an i seem
fun spotify list is spotify the one
where you erin witt spotify you make a
mix it's not Pandora right that's it
that's a different thing Pandora no but
Spotify is like I'm making a mix based
on how beautiful Jenna's like that's
them right ok that's what's happening
but it's about my podcast so either and
so if you go to a twitter at I seem fun
podcast and you tweet out what's the
Spotify address I'll help you find it
cuz I don't remember but thank you for
liking the music I have ok taste in
music at 20 year olds think my taste in
music is amazing because what with the
internet and everything they have no
ability to go back and find out anything
that happened before but I like the
basic good stuff like as far as punk
goes I like The Ramones and the Sex
Pistols real punks would be like and you
have to know about skulls in the face
and they never made an album that's how
Punk there and I'm like okay well I
don't know that and you know I like funk
it all like Sly and the Family Stone I
like but people who are really into
FUNKER like you have to know flew benue
and then so I I know like the basics of
good all kinds of music but um and I'll
even the pop I like is good i just heard
that who is that person had to pretend
to like don't believe it just watch and
not kendrick lamar dancefloor rainbow
what's his name bumpin Bruno Mars it
awful awful not interesting I'd rather
listen to what he thinks he sounds like
but anyway so thank you for liking my
music my taste isn't that good and you
as you say just have a generation that
listens to [ __ ] which I don't I mean I
think those like what I call air raid
signal music that's like armor like I've
been taking them this exercise class in
addition to my normal like all
lady pilates and walking sometimes I'll
take this class called pop physique and
it's the such a small room it only fits
like 15 people comfortably if they're
moving around and the woman that teaches
it wears a headset mic and uh performed
for more people with no mic and she and
she's all like de storages talking on it
like that's back that up but Dad up up
that's right small moments up up up and
perfect i meant papa and you've no idea
what she's saying and then because she's
screaming over this music that's like
and I'm like if you just turned that
[ __ ] down then we could hear what you're
saying so whatever that music is is
awful and then you know my rant about
the black keys when I saw them a
southern music festival they played at
night Billy Idol had taken his shirt off
in his leather pants at 4pm playing the
old people show guitarist was ripping he
was amazing he was a showman his
attitude was like I will [ __ ] all of you
right now simultaneously with this one
dick and then the black keys got up and
they looked like they had dropped
something down there shirt and they
couldn't find it in their bra heads down
just like me like good then don't
perform if you don't want to look at me
so if you're talking about them I agree
but I think there's a lot of great music
I think you guys should get into some of
my friends bands like um do you know Ted
Leo and Aimee Mann have a great band i'm
soo my great friends i'm saying that
sounded named Rafi that's not how I
meant it but you gotta get into 10 Leo's
music aimee mann and then they have a
band together called both which is great
and I feel like anything that's new
wouldn't you call that of your
generation it's a like there's new music
coming out all the time and we're all
different ages so isn't it all of our
generations music so you must mean do
you mean music that's geared towards
20-somethings by other 20-somethings or
like I don't know if you mean the rock
music is [ __ ] or the dance music is [ __ ]
but i don't i don't know what's that
band the
I keep thinking thought Bell Biv DeVoe
it's like quiet people not down
Sebastian it's like three names neutral
not neutral milk hotel who cares I'm
there's a band out there that I bet I
hate but I've never heard them great
story ok ok so then he says is that
legal without paying royalties so he's
not being ridden no it is not legal um
the way that I get away with playing the
songs is that I don't like I play them
on a boom boom boom box says 100 year
old woman I play them on a speaker and I
talk over them and I don't play them
that long and it's known as parody it'd
be awesome if you can start a list in
the description of each episode or don't
I don't give a [ __ ] thank you for being
realistic I probably won't but there are
lots of people out there person whose
name I won't say they're in their
cubicles and they have started a Spotify
list and I in my when I've done live I
seem fun shows my opening pre-show music
is always songs that have been played on
the podcast there's one song I remember
big fun bike home making ok you can
listen to that over and over ok um just
an FYI I just tried to write mental
health in the subject line and my this
is someone else ok sorry thanks why
won't you let me use your name oh let's
talk about more about traveling alone so
I have a show in London come out and see
me London this is your plug i'll be at
the Soho Theatre in London I've said
that 10 times April twenty-eighth no not
Nate what the last week I had one I
forgot to go I hope you enjoyed it I
hope they give you a refund July
eighteenth through the 24th just six
shows one night only no opening act I
come right on I start it's a goddamn
cabaret and I treat it with respect and
then I get offstage and I had backstage
for a minute and
I'm doing something important and then I
come out and I will be selling copies of
my new book I know what I'm doing
another lies i tell myself Aaron that's
your new favorite book for summer right
beat read mm-hmm and then I'll sign it
and I think i'm going to sell it for 20
pounds and that's it and that's a
discount btdubs so what was I saying oh
so after that it's July and I think when
you're in London it's a good time you
can't just if you have time off if
you're like me and you live a life of
luxury if you go to London and you don't
have to get right back home you're a
dingbat if you don't take a little money
and go to at least one other country
they're all easy to get to it's like if
you live in Maine you take it to ride to
Connecticut right so don't do the math
on the mileage but I'm going to Venice
Italy I've never been I googled it I
mean I knew what it was I did extensive
research which means i googled it and
read three tripadvisor comments and it
seems to be the safest city for a woman
alone in Italy now Naples is supposed to
be the most gorgeous but it's a lot of
dudes like on street corners okay baby
and not that i don't mind getting cat
called in Italy but I don't know the
culture well enough to know if I can go
like a [ __ ] like a sassy broad or
someone's going to kill me now I don't
assume they have as many guns as we have
here or any but I don't know with those
beautiful Italian shoes I feel like they
can run like bastards and come after me
and I feel like I shouldn't say it it's
going to trigger someone I feel like sex
against your will there is just like a
so what like I just so I'm just trying
to be safe but what was my point oh I've
always wanted to go and I love some
alone time because I could tell you
after doing the shows in London and I'm
doing Manchester july twenty fourth at
the pub zoo it's my debut so I couple
hundred seats so definitely get tickets
now it's on my website jen kirkman calm
click tour dates and then i'll be at the
suffolk latitude music
Valon july 23rd so that's a lot for my
voice so anyone in this room does not
know i have vocal nodules I'm not
supposed to talk more than hour a day
while I'm in recovery I should not be
touring but I am because I love the fans
I [ __ ] gotten this thing on Twitter
last night I'll tell you about that
later um so I want three days alone
where I don't to speak and I don't have
to speak in Italy because i can't speak
italy ish and so i won't i got an
English speaking tour guide to take me
around for one day and not like a
walking tour not like I get in someone's
car and drive like it's I picture
roberto benigni just like is beautiful
here and like I'm just like help and I'm
stuck in a car but um so remember when
everyone loved him they were like he
makes us feel good and he would just
come on two awards shows and just be
like you Americans this is not serious
his life is beautiful and just run
around like a maniac weird it where has
he been I feel like he needs to step in
and make us feel amazing again because
everyone is so angry about everything
with the election and now Johnny Depp is
beating people what the [ __ ] okay I do
anyone have a pen do have a pen I need
to make notes about and this is supposed
to listen or email episode but I seem to
can't stop talking so we're going to get
into traveling alone as our friend who
won't let me say his name wrote in oh my
god you're a dream so r into what Johnny
Depp is beating everybody and I guess
that was it i didn't i just had to write
down Johnny Depp so the day that he okay
let me just finish this Italy thing so
I'm gonna go for three days and walk
around and a few people have in like
you're going alone oh that's like listen
even if I were in a relationship which I
might be by then you don't know what's
going on in my life and that would not
be the ideal situation for the
relationship because it would be me
whenever I perform for 10 days I have to
go on vocal rest for three days after
which means not speak
really so instead of fly home and sit in
my apartment quietly I'll go to Venice
[ __ ] so I'm not sad about it I'm I
love seeing things and the worst thing
is when you're with someone and you're
trying to like mold them into someone
they're not you're like why don't you
appreciate this and they don't and then
you're like but it's beautiful and
imagine if you didn't have to tell
someone that they're wrong about
everything all the time or like just
find out stuff about someone you don't
want to know like I can't believe they
don't care where grapes come from and
you never have to know that about
someone okay anyways so I hear you for
traveling alone on your own around the
US would you write back and tell us
where you've been I actually interested
in your fun trips I loved last summer I
drove God through Iowa Nebraska Kansas
Missouri missourah as I was taught to
say as a kid and no one really says that
you know in a word you're pronouncing it
correctly but you sound like an [ __ ]
we I know it's technically missourah but
I won't say it I just started getting
comfortable saying Oregon so I will
never say nawlins I feel like an [ __ ]
my mother it's nawlins gen that's how
they say so alright Johnny Depp beating
everybody and I think it's funny to say
everybody so don't her name is Amber um
here's my thing with that and then his
ex well I guess vanessa paradis was
never his wife they just had kids for
for 14 years together and continue to
kids didn't die just cuz they're not
there anymore I guess we have to murder
the children now that's so sad mmm so
she came out and said I can't believe
this he was always so amazing to me and
I feel like we're the internet sucks is
there's no nuance it's like I'm with
Amber and then the other people are like
I'm gonna wait and see I love when
people think they're so smart when
they're like well we don't know all the
stories yet I'm gonna wait and see oh
shut up if someone says they're beaten
there they probably were beaten unless
she wants to unless she's so [ __ ] nut
that she doesn't care that we might
eventually find out it's not true no
woman is like you know what I can't wait
to do get online and talk about my rape
or being beaten because people are going
to be amazing about it no one wants that
it's going to be really good for my
career to go up against the most famous
beloved man who's you know wearing
costumes all the time and making kids
laugh Johnny Depp has become our clown
you know you realize that right he's
like he's our roberto benigni like but
he's quieter he's like I don't know I
just put on them I'm a pirate and then
um I love someone derlin and then um um
sometimes I'm have scissors in my hands
and sometimes him you know it's do it
for the kids you know but here's the
thing about the years and this is the
final say I'm correct I go to therapy
psychology is my part-time job if you
are abusive to a woman it doesn't mean
you are abusive to every woman you're
with I am NOT abusive but I for example
uh always was this is a terrible example
but I always was a type of person who
had a crush on everyone I'm flirty I
don't want to come in I don't want to
settle down and that kind of lifestyle
ladies was causing me a lot of angst and
pain in my 20s you know unavailable men
or men who are like cool I don't want
anything either and then I fall in love
with them or the other way around and it
was just like you know what let me just
pick someone and settle down and so I
met someone at 30 we were together until
his 37 we were married for two of those
years in those seven years I completely
managed to squash all that flirtations I
would have with other people and all
that since I need of drama and of having
you know any pic of any guys and stuff
like that i squashed it and then when I
got divorced I was I who that was crazy
and then this analogy makes no sense i
almost want to stop it'll just finish
and then i went back to you know running
around and then now I know
that you don't just pick someone to
settle down with and I know that for me
I would like a committed monogamous
relationship and so that is what I do
now but it took a lot of work to get
there this is not the same I'm not
comparing it but I'm saying it is
perhaps possible in the abuser cycle
that Johnny Depp is not good at conflict
in relationships he is triggered by a
certain kind of person who is triggered
by him these people in life find each
other two magnets game matches game
trauma attracts drama so maybe Vanessa
wasn't that type for him maybe that's
why they ended up breaking up maybe he
had given it 14 years and he was ready
to go nuts again but I'm saying maybe
amber they certainly got married within
months of knowing each other which is
never a great sign that things are
healthy and they probably are both a
little bit nuts and i am not saying she
deserve to be beaten no no sir no sir
but they probably had this dynamic of
trauma drama maybe the first couple
times something happened she was like
that's weird maybe I pushed him to it
I'll stay everyone should be forgiven he
was high he was this and then it gets
bad and then people's resentment come up
for having stayed and they act more
angry and then the angry abuser is
losing control and they hate that person
and it's an awful complex cycle and I
have domestic violence in not my
immediate family to do with my family
but people in my family have been the
victims of domestic violence and that's
exactly what happens now Johnny Depp may
not be someone who is domestically abuse
of to Vanessa but that doesn't mean he
wasn't this time also there's allegedly
some cocaine use I don't know if there
is but if there's cocaine going on that
can hurt things and maybe let's say he
hadn't been on it the last 14 years and
whatever so it's a sick messy situation
and I hate writing it off as he's an
abuser who hates women it's like he's a
sick
sick person and so is someone who
unfortunately is the victim of domestic
violence there is a sickness there if
they stayed for more than one second and
then there's the sickness of getting
over it so everybody's sick it's very
tragic what the problem is in society is
when people don't believe the woman as
though like with Janice Dickinson i
believe all the Cosby victims except her
why cuz she's crazy okay but crazy
people are victims of stuff too well
they shouldn't be i only like perfect
victims so okay great boring story
everyone's mad at me but if you i read a
great book about the 90s called
champagne supernova thank God it's known
about that terrible band oasis it was
about how kate moss and Marc Jacobs rose
to fame and the real story of like 90s
fashion and the grunge movement it's
[ __ ] fascinating to I think men will
love it straight men you actually might
it's a lot there's a lot of business
stuff in there not like men only need to
hear about business and Lanie's up to
hear about clothing but it's it's a cool
book there so I think there's something
in it for everyone you got your early
New York 90s scene it's all about music
and that's what it's about the [ __ ] is
wrong with me it's from music and
fashion defining the 90s but
accidentally they didn't mean to come
together they just did so if you like
the grunge scene if you like stories
about pretty girls on drugs you got
everything in that book and so kate moss
and johnny depp trashing hotels now you
think oh they're just trashing hotels i
bet it was ass domestic squabble and
they were throwing things at each other
or he was so angry he trashed a hotel
because they just found out one of the
fights he had with amber he punched a
wall and he blamed it on filming pirates
the caribbean which is odd because the
staff and cast and crew of pirates the
caribbean must have been like no you
didn't we have everything on tape and
he's like okay and he just ignores it
but so anyway i think the man as I was
probably then violent and I think he's
always mentioned in the book some
cocaine use so it seems like cocaine is
a thing I've heard stories he did start
the Viper Room that johnny was always
the guy you go to
when you need to find some drugs not
saying he would give it to you maybe
that's what he keeps into scarves I
don't [ __ ] know but he knows the
people who know the people and this is
all allegedly and maybe I should list
all the slander i say right up there
with all the music i'm playing in the
description alright that was boring not
funny everyone's mad alright next
question hi Jen I truly enjoy listening
to your podcast and one of the reasons
is because you are an advocate for
mental health I am I work in mental
health on the counselor and so many
people have such little knowledge about
what mental health counseling and social
work really is so I just wanted to say
thank you from someone who works in the
field we need more voices to speak about
the importance of taking care of your
brain and emotions that you guys is a
coincidence I didn't know that was the
next letter I feel like I don't do
enough to call myself an advocate I
mainly just yell at people on Twitter
who say stupid [ __ ] like seeing my
friends is my therapy no it's not um
what was I saying I got into it was
someone on Twitter about something Oh
sharks here's the thing this woman who
swam a mile and a half into the ocean
for her triathlon I'm not saying it's
her fault or she was asking for it but
she's assessing the risk for sure of
getting eaten by shark she knows that
there's stuff I think you can do like I
don't mean like she sprayed something on
her welcome for mosquitoes but there's
certain I don't know she understands her
sharks I'm sure she took some
precautions or some kind of thing in
case they bite love habla someone say
it's her fault I'm saying it's a we all
have risks with our job me my voice a
shark just my thing is the language
don't use shark attack sharks don't have
brains they're not like I'm going to
attack someone they're dumb they don't
even like they can't even like move
their neck just imagine if you like your
neck was an embrace all the time and you
can't like turn to the right or left and
your giant and you're just like threw in
the ocean that's a shark that they're
out of control because they don't have
next so that's not their fault they
can't they're not attacking anyone they
see something near
and they start biting it wouldn't you if
you couldn't move your neck and
something came up behind you would you
be like well I don't want to get a bad
reputation I'm sure it's nothing even
though I live in this house alone that
there you're in their house we throw
trash in the [ __ ] ocean and then we
go surf in it on things that look like
animals that a shark eats we're like I
got hooked now I'm not victim-blaming so
someone said your victim blaming I said
no call it a shark bite or shark
accident I don't go a truck attacked me
on the freeway know if we had Scott and
its way or it was just an accident I
just think if you bump into a shark it
might use its teeth it might not even
mean to use its teeth again their mouths
are always [ __ ] open they are not
there beautiful animals but they don't
have brains we do and we're [ __ ]
stupid so imagine how dumb a shark is ok
I am pro shark always will be till the
day I die don't care don't care about
people who get bit by them I'm
fascinated and I someday would like to
be eaten by a shark that's how I want to
die I don't want to die but if I have to
that's how I want to go so I'd like to
live to 100 and then just throw me in
the ocean but the thing that sucks about
it is I don't want to drown but I
imagine the pain would be so bad the
endorphins kick in which might be kind
of fun and then you lose all your blood
and you faint so in a weird way it's
kind of a relaxing way to die ok um once
ok i have my pages out of order oh god
damn it you guys ok oh this is a juicy
one hang I have to take some water my
arm is numb that's a vocal warmup I'm
supposed to do ok hi Jen you can use my
name no I won't just in case hang on
hang on hang on you guys have to get
comfortable how's the periscope going
are people saying rude things like your
dumb [ __ ] oh that's even better is
anyone watching
let me check my Twitter let's see what
they're saying no one's called me a
corporate [ __ ] or anything like that if
I even say like Hillary Clinton is a
person who's breathing they're like you
[ __ ] corporate [ __ ] alright
nevermind I can't even say nice things
about anybody is there a band playing in
here is this rehearsal studios they
sound like a real band maybe we can get
autographs okay okay so a little over
this is a email from someone so a little
over a year ago my boyfriend came to me
with the news that he had been seeing
his ex girlfriend while I was working
and that she was pregnant he decided to
do the right thing and go back with her
and the two got married pretty quickly
well honey if you didn't work he
wouldn't have cheated and this is why
more women should stop working because
you can't keep a man with that
insistence on getting health insurance
and a paycheck okay now i'm still a
young man whoa Aaron do you understand
this the sky had a boyfriend but he says
he's still a young man how can you have
a boyfriend if you're a mint he's a gay
man I I'm sorry you guys I did not know
I had gained listeners and I hope is
anyone here offended triggered I just
try to keep it straight and white I'm
just kidding I love that you're like
actually answering okay okay so this
seems like your ex-boyfriend was a
bisexual because he went back with his
girlfriend and I always misguidedly
think if someone left me
for like if a guy left me for a guy I
wouldn't be as offended if he left me
for a woman because I don't have what he
needs so you you aren't a woman so why
are you offended which is the dumbest
attitude okay all right this is juicy so
everyone's on board right a man let's
start over a little over a year ago my
boyfriend can't look he said I can use
his name oh he didn't put his name oh I
didn't print his name let's call you Jim
all right so Jim's boyfriend came to him
and said I've been seeing my
ex-girlfriend we were working and she's
pregnant I'm going to do the right thing
and go back with her and then the two
got married pretty quickly now jim says
I'm still a young man so I'm not worried
about whether or not I'm going to meet
someone new there's plenty of time and
to be honest being single again has been
quite nice I've become a netflix
aficionado and now no the pizza delivery
guys by name it's fun the problem is my
ex his wife and their baby have recently
moved back into my neighborhood and I've
ran into them a couple times oh that
part isn't so fun small talk talk sucks
at the best of times but this is next
level whenever I see them I feel so
humiliated and start to have all of
these feelings of insecurity that this
sort of situation brings back I never
even really told anyone what happened
because it's so embarrassing but now
that he's back I guess people are going
to find out what happened how do I stop
feeling so crappy about this it's gotten
to the point that dread that I dread
going out to places he might be I don't
want him back or anything weird and
self-destructive like that but I'm
starting to really feel down on myself
about it again any advice you have a be
awesome my only plan so far is either
move or higher above pretend boyfriend
in the style of some 90s rom-com which
so rarely works out well thanks for the
great podcast okay well if you are going
to get a fake boyfriend do not pattern
it after a 90s rom-com those never work
out the only time they work out is in
hallmark christmas movies there's
many many fantastic hallmark made-for-tv
Christmas movies where a woman and a man
both put in the classifieds that they
need to meet a boyfriend or a girlfriend
for the holidays so their family gets
off they dick and they meet and they
fall them up so don't despair you can do
that just you have to watch hallmark
movies I'm going to break this down
first of all you feel you you said you
feel humiliated and have feelings of
insecurity I've never told anyone what
happened because it's so embarrassing
that's how you stop feeling crappy
you're only as sick as your secrets you
have to start telling people and don't
be a burden to one person spread it out
you know give everyone the CliffsNotes
tell a couple of your friends and just
tell them you feel really crappy and
guess what when you open up to people
people will open up to you I don't know
if you can go to therapy I always
recommend that the other thing I
recommend read any and all self-help
books about just take care of yourself I
would do this you're going to keep
running into them and it's going to get
easier and it seems like unless like you
were just this weird mistake he made no
offense and his really meant to be with
this woman in the kid it sounds like he
might do something like this again and
do it to her so don't compare as I would
say I didn't make this up your insides
with their outsides they might be
miserable we don't hope that they are
that doesn't make your life any better
but we're just saying you're going to
have those feelings just say to yourself
I don't have to do anything about these
feelings today you're doing great
already by not reacting right you're not
sending them crazy texts or making it
his problem if you are do not but it
sounds like you're not and you feel bad
okay so we have feelings we can't help
it we feel bad that's all you have to do
in those moments is feel bad and you
actually don't even know them small talk
he kind of [ __ ] you over so you might
want to say to him if you ever see him
alone I am NOT angry but I would love to
not have to a deal with this and
I would appreciate if we run into each
other if we can just nod and be grateful
for the time we had but I don't want to
engage in small talk and you can say
that to him I would not start that
conversation offline like don't email
him that or text him but if you ever see
them and if you only see them in this
family unit then don't say it then but I
don't know where you run into him but
you know if you're walking down the
street that's kind of tough to blow
someone off but you might just start
with oh hey great to see you guys I'm I
gotta run though I'm late they probably
don't mean they might not want to be
around you either they might feel
awkward as well time will do its thing
and you'll feel better but what's really
happening is you're not talking to
anyone about it and you have to everyone
gets embarrassed because when someone
[ __ ] us over like that we feel like
losers because we didn't see it coming
and we shouldn't feel that way it's not
our fault sometimes we don't see things
coming because we don't want to and so
the more you talk to people about it the
more you're going to get better at not
picking someone like that next time
because you'll have people to be
accountable to in your life you know
let's say you start talking people about
this and then you meet a new guy and
there's some similarities your friends
could be like um you know this sounds
like Jimmy and his family so you can't
feel down on yourself it's too you're
just wasting your time it'sit's to
victim II you already feel bad so that's
enough don't go down don't go down
yourself I mean you could go down if you
can go down on yourself put it on
youtube you'll be rich but don't get
down on yourself because you're just
wallowing it's time taken away where you
could be helping others or enjoying your
life don't waste this gift of a life
adding feeling bad for yourself you
already feel bad you already feel that
think of it as if you cut your arm you
have to give it time to heal would you
scream at the cut and be like why are
you cut you stupid arm you just you go
on with it you know you have to act as
if you have to keep going on with your
life
you feel shitty that is called how
everyone [ __ ] feels every 10 minutes
okay great um of what okay so what's
this about uh okay what okay here's
something how did okay I'm in the middle
of a page I must have cut and paste or
wrong this letter starts that I'm very
close with I am the least organized
person and that aspect of my life is
what keeping me okay so this guy is
trying to move is what it sounds like
the thought of leaving all these people
especially my parents makes me a little
sad because I don't want to miss out on
their lives or them miss out on mine and
I don't want to lose the precious
valuable time I have left with them
moving across the country doesn't align
with spending more time with them
however I need to get the [ __ ] out of
this place and do something great with
my life and Las Vegas is calling my name
okay so he's from Portland Maine and he
hasn't found his people in life he
doesn't find anything around there to be
exciting he doesn't like the snow he's a
vegan with a culinary degree and he only
has a desire to work in the vegan field
in some capacity with food he's madly in
love with Vegas after visiting it twice
he loves the climate landscape energy in
the desert um but he's got a lot of
close friends and family in Maine I know
the move doesn't have to be permanent
good one and I could come back any time
I just think that I'll love it out there
so much that I won't want to come back
and besides my friends and family
there's nothing else I would want to
come back here for anyway I know you
moved away from your family when you
were young and now let excuse me that's
rude right Arizona brenton you got the
subtle thing there when i was i'm still
young no I know you're saying when I was
just a pup and now live on the opposite
side of the country's them so I'm wonder
how you dealt with the fact that moving
away means missing out and seeing less
of the people you love what is the
adjustment of creating a new life with
new friends like to seeing aging parents
less and less over time affect you I
would love to hear any advice ok first
of all I was a giant [ __ ] when I moved
to LA I would know I moved to New York
when I was 23 and that didn't affect me
because it's a four-hour train ride I
came back to Boston all the time to
still do comedy there see my best
friends and my family so that was
easy-peasy and then when I moved to LA
at 27 um it was hard but the calling for
the what I mean my parents made me
knowing that I don't have the kind of
family that pressures me they're like
whatever you want to do I'm not saying
yours does but I I didn't have that
sense of there was just nothing for me
to do there and I wanted to live in LA
and my parents wanted me to I mean it's
exciting for them and I moved here for
my career but at the time I was in love
with someone and i moved to be with him
so I wasn't really thinking straight and
then I have always been the type of
person that's like even though I don't
like meeting new people and making new
friends i get a little especially after
I moved to LA and made new friends I was
like who I picked some doozies at first
you know I'm the person that's like
she's so nice she's in a cult you know
like I never get people right at first
I'm getting better at that so um it was
easy for me because the the does desire
to be here was so strong that I was
miserable anywhere else and then I
wasn't getting along with my family my
family and I were having major problems
when I moved here so it was kind of easy
and I wasn't big on family back then I
was like [ __ ] them and so I moved in
kind of a [ __ ] everyone scenario but it
sounds like you've got the right idea
and now you know and so I started seeing
my family a couple times a year instead
of once a month and it got harder but
then again there is email so we do email
my sister
and i text a lot and I actually see them
now in the quality time is better have
relatives in Massachusetts so aging
parents yes I mean I can't take care of
them physically but I worry I needed
like for example I have to go to New
York next week no big deal what I'm
going to be on the two dopes Queens
podcast and I'm gonna go to New York for
a few days and I'm like I'm kind of no
one in my family would care but I feel
like I'm being a dick if I don't go to
Boston for a day to see them so I'm
flying in there spending the night
saying hello and that's what I do I'm
the only one that visits my family
doesn't visit me I'm the one with the
money I'm a one percenter you guys and
so I will spend the money to fly there a
couple times a year so I feel like I see
them just as much but more quality and
so if you get that vegan business going
and you've got enough money you could
see them pretty often and like my dad
did fall down because he's older and he
was sick and I got to take a week off
work at the time I had a writing job and
I got to spend a week in the hospital
with him and cuz I had some extra bucks
I got to pay for this really gorgeous
hotel suite and have my sister's come
stay within my mom because it was a
snowstorm and so my dad had hit his head
he was in the hospital during a terrible
snowstorm in Boston you couldn't drive
anywhere and so my sister and my mom and
lived an hour from the hospital we're
kind of [ __ ] I come into town
corporate [ __ ] here voting for Hillary
in the what I'm not really in the
one-percent I just say that to piss
people off I come to town uh with all
the money Bill Clinton gave me from
settling his assault cases and I got a
nice hotel for my family to stay and we
stayed there for a week and we were able
to visit my dad so if because I left
town to follow my dreams I was able to
be there for my family in a way I
couldn't have been had I stayed around
and right so you never know
it could definitely bring inspiration to
your family it could bring more money to
you which can help everybody and there's
an adjustment but this is your life not
theirs and they would be more sad that
you didn't go i'm assuming everyone that
you know friends and family they're
doing what they want for a living if
you're not it's not worth it and as
parents get sick there are airplanes we
can get there in five hours and once it
gets to the level where they are needing
to be in a nursing home or you know
whatever then you can maybe you could I
don't know do both maybe you could take
some time off and help care for them but
I know what you're saying it's more
about you want to see them as much as
possible before they die I believe we
just have to keep keeping that in mind
no matter where we live great story you
could go visit your parents you could be
living in Maine and you could be like oh
you guys I can't come over for dinner
tonight and then your parents can go
outside and a bird takes a [ __ ] on them
and then they fall and hit their heads
and they die and you'll be like oh my
god they still died even though I lived
a mile away okay I'm as a vegan who well
no I'm not a cheating vegan anymore
because i don't need eggs anymore so i
would like to eat at your wherever you
cook in vegas like make sure it's a
restaurant i'm not going to come to your
weird hotel room with a hot plate get it
going and then i'll i'll do it okay we
should end this now right yeah I usually
do an hour but I was late I'll do five
more minutes and then we'll wrap up if
this is the most I say every so episodes
the most boring and they are but this
really is born Oh people want to know
about has offensive stuff hindered okay
because I talked about this cashier who
had a stump who hit on me at midnight a
grocery store made me feel uncomfortable
not as it was stumped but because he got
my change wrong and then told me that
the compliment he gave me went to my
head and I was like no you just [ __ ]
didn't give me my money back
but the way he complimented me was weird
he like leaned in and said something
like I shouldn't be at a grocery store
alone at night like his own my life was
said and I was just buying water because
i had not for without a [ __ ] explain
why i went to a grocery store and so but
i was very nervous about saying that and
this woman said big fan I wanted to say
i appreciated that episode the thing is
you're not being offensive by
questioning ideas maybe I'm being
paranoid but it really seems like
questioning things has now become
offensive and hateful does this hinder
your comedy I've been going to open mics
and it really seems like a lot of people
are pretty afraid to give opinions that
are critical not even offensive in the
context of doing stand-up you you even
do it a few times in your episode where
you have to go not that I'm saying guys
with stumps can't be confident but I do
find people have to go look I'm not
saying blah blah I honestly think this
hurts open and free discussion I know
the pc issue has been beaten to death I
just think stand-up should be bold and
unafraid to go places to make things
funny I agree a Brian but the thing is
on the podcast these are written out
jokes I'm talking off the top of my head
and it's the way i would talk in
conversation i would want people to it
exclusively and exactly know that i'm
not saying people without with stumps
can't be great and that's how i talk in
conversation and that's the charm if you
will of this podcast is that I you're
letting your seeing you lucky people my
thought process and even you now are
singing on periscope and in my stand-up
I would never derail a joke i mean like
and then some people have stumped spent
their dicks but then other people have
stumps and they're nice I don't do that
unless I write it in a funny way so it
doesn't hinder my stand-up because I
don't really feel like I talk about
anything controversial if I do I have a
reason and I make it funny if you make
them laugh they can't think that's
offensive if they're offended most
likely someone didn't make something
funny and that's why I give disclaimers
on this podcast because it's it's fun
but it's not necessarily funny because i
haven't had it's not about writing
punchlines it's about talking
extemporaneously ooh big word must be
nice
alright the last one that's boring Oh
someone said what's the nicest thing as
strangers ever done for you I don't know
about ever but recently in my mania when
I went to see b2 and bought two lamps in
a table for no reason I pulled up in
front of my own apartment building took
the boxes out of my car and this man and
his wife were walking their dog and he's
like he was a German guys like I help
you and then he just took the boxes
carried them up my steps put them inside
the building and pushed them into the
elevator for me and I thought that was
so nice and then I almost wanted to ask
them if they would just do the whole
thing like just come upstairs and bring
it into my apartment but I was like
that's weird but that was super nice
because as I was pulling up to the curb
I was like you know what people suck and
in the 30s people helped each other they
also put each other in concentration
camps so I can't you know I if there's
not going to be concentration camps I'll
take the other part of it which is
people don't help each other anymore but
it seems that they do okay blah blah
blah that's boring why'd I print that no
offense what you don't know what I'm
talking about someone is wondering she's
34 no kids not planning any for the
first time she's experiencing oh you
don't have kids she's finding hard to
deal with it seems as though having
children allows them flexibility of
bending the rules at work like I can't
stay late today it's my kids first dance
show or I can't do the early shift
because my kids don't get up that early
it's the assumption that because I don't
have kids that I'll just fill in and I
feel left on the hook it's really
starting to irritate me and I'm not sure
how much longer I can just smile and
keep going it's frustrating they can
leave early for a sick kid but I can't
leave early to get to a show in the city
on time or dinner and drinks with
friends why am I penalized for not
procreating how do you deal with it YB
I'm a stand-up so I don't have to deal
with this [ __ ] I don't have to deal with
anyone being like I have kids I can't
I'm though I'm the boss and the employee
but when I've had jobs yes people with
kids get to leave
and I see that as now I see it as the
same as me going to a doctor's
appointment I don't think it's quite the
same as me wanting to leave early to go
to a show because they don't want to
watch their kids [ __ ] dance show they
have to they don't want to it does seem
like we pick up the slack and I think we
do I didn't think that's just gonna have
to be how it is how I deal that you can
find out by reading my new york times
bestselling book I can barely take care
of myself tales from a happy life
without kids but yeah I just don't
comment and I distance myself and I'm
like oh well and if it's really a slack
I can't pick up i'm like i can't sorry
and you don't have to tell them what
you're doing I feel like no one should
even have to be like I'm picking up my
kid just [ __ ] leave work when you
want what it would it's good when I
worked can you play America the
Beautiful unjustly when I worked in
the.com industry in 1999 we were told
someday there will soon because of the
invention of the laptop there won't be
offices anymore we'll all work from home
you don't need to go to offices anymore
and there's more offices than ever I've
been researching it now I don't know why
are we bringing the laptop to offices we
should all be home and we can skype in a
meaning what what the [ __ ] are we doing
no one should have to say where they're
going and no one should have to go to
work period ok that's the end of this
episode I hope you all enjoyed the live
periscope from the all things comedy
studio here's what you guys are going to
do you're going to go to all things
comedy calm and enjoy all the many
podcasts so many that producer Aaron
does not have time to listen to mine but
now it's his new favorite he can't get
enough Brendan and Cassie you can't get
enough either and everyone in periscope
they can and have had enough and you can
go to my website jen kirkman calm click
on tour dates here's where I'm coming in
the next couple months and they're on
sale now London Manchester UK Milwaukee
that's not up yet vermont Burlington Los
Angeles big show at the improv Tuesday
the eighteenth I'm doing a new comedy
special at the end of sep tember they
won't let me tell you what network it's
with
yet I don't know why well I dunno why
they do this all the time and I'm doing
that new hour then so please come I seem
funders to that all tickets on my
website jen kirkman calm i will be in
scottsdale arizona at stand-up
Scottsdale labor day weekend if you're
not a rich [ __ ] you can go on vacation
go sit outside of the restaurant that
sprays water at you and then come see my
show I'll be in buffalo new york and
portland oregon is well in September
those tickets aren't on sale yet and I'm
taping my comedy special in New York
City at the bowery ballroom October
first save that date it is also not on
sale yet Jen Kirkman calm / about to get
on my email list i'll be doing a couple
shows here and there at the end of the
year get my books [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] people
just go to my website and buy the [ __ ]
out of everything you can go to my merch
page by I seem fun merchandise you can
do whatever the [ __ ] you want and I hope
you enjoy it and until next week out fun
you